>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
THIS FRIDAY NIGHT.
WE OPEN WITH A QUESTION TONIGHT.
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
TWO YEARS AGO BECAUSE IN FOUR
DAYS YOU'LL HAVE A CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AT THE BALLOT BOX.
NOW ONLY YOU CAN CHECK JOE BIDEN
AND THE RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
ONLY YOU CAN HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE YEARS OF
LIES AND ABUSE.
TONIGHT THAT ABUSE IS NOW
REACHING A BOILING POINT.
THE DEMOCRATS, THEIR CLOSING
MESSAGE TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, IS AMERICANS THAT DON'T
VOTE FOR US ARE NAZIS.
YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN A
COUNTRY THAT FOLLOWS WHAT
HAPPENED IN GERMANY IN THE EARLY
'30s.
AND I SAID THIS IN 2018, AND
CAUGHT A LOT OF HELL FROM A LOT
OF PEOPLE FOR HAVING SAID IT,
BUT IT WAS TRUE THEN AND IT'S
TRUE NOW.
THIS COUNTRY IS ON TRACK TO
REPEAT WHAT HAPPENED IN GERMANY
WHEN IT WAS THE GREATEST
DEMOCRACY GOING, ELECTED A
CHANCELLOR WHO THEN CO-OP'D THE
MEDIA.
>> Sean: DEVOID OF ANYTHING
POSITIVE AT ALL THEY CAN RUN ON,
DEMOCRATS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
BEGIN UP FEAR BY DEHUMANIZING
HALF THE COUNTRY.
THIS WEEK ALONE THEY COMPARED,
LET'S SEE, REPUBLICANS SUBURBAN
WOMEN TO ROACHES.
THEY COMPARED CONSERVATIVES TO
NAZIS.
THEY ACCUSED US OF PLOTTING TO
OVERTHROW DEMOCRACY.
THEY SAID THAT AMERICA'S STREETS
WILL RUN RED WITH BLOOD IF
REPUBLICANS GET ELECTED.
WE'RE NOT EXAGGERATING.
WE REPORT.
YOU DECIDE.
>> OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE OUR DEMOCRACY
IS AT RISK, THAT DEMOCRACY IS
UNDER THREAT.
THEY TOO SEE THAT DEMOCRACY IS
ON THE BALLOT THIS YEAR.
THEY'RE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
IT.
>> WHAT WAS AT STAKE TONIGHT,
AND THIS WEEK, WAS THE FACT,
WHETHER WE WILL BE A DEMOCRACY
IN THE FUTURE, WHETHER OUR
CHILDREN WILL BE ARRESTED AND
CONCEIVABLY KILLED.
WE'RE ON THE EDGE OF A BRUTAL
AUTHORITARIAN SYSTEM.
>> WHITE REPUBLICAN SUBURBAN
WOMEN ARE NOW GOING TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
>> WHY?
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE ROACHES
VOTING FOR RAID.
>> THEY'RE PUSHING OUT ALL THESE
POLLS TO MUDDY UP THE AVERAGES,
AND CREATE THE NARRATIVE OF A
RED WAVE.
IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN, AREN'T WE
GOING TO BE IN MORE DANGER OF
VIOLENCE, BECAUSE THEY'VE
CREATED A NARRATIVE, AND IF IT
HADN'T HAPPEN THEY'LL SAY THE
WHOLE ELECTRIC WAS STOLEN.
>> WE'RE SEEING A WHOLE
POLITICAL PARTY, AND THOSE WHO
SUPPORT IT, ENABLE IT, RUN UNDER
ITS BANNER, ENGAGING IN BEHAVIOR
THAT IS SO DANGEROUS.
I FIND FRANKLY DISQUALIFYING FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE RUNNING FOR
OFFICE.
OF THE.
>> Sean: CHILDREN ARRESTED,
THEY'RE GOING TO BE KILLED, NAZI
GERMANY ANALOGIES AND SUBURBAN
WOMEN THAT VOTE REPUBLICAN.
IT'S LIKE ROACHES VOTING FOR
RAID.
ACCORDING TO THE LEFT, THE ONLY
CRISIS IN AMERICA IS REPUBLICANS
WHO WIN AN ELECTION.
VIOLENT CRIME IS A VAST RIGHT
WING CONSPIRACY THEORY IN THEIR
WORLD, THE BORDER BEING TOTALLY
OUT OF CONTROL?
NO.
IT'S SECURE, IF YOU LISTEN TO
THEM.
GAS PRICES, ACCORDING TO THE
DEMOCRATS ARE REALLY LOW.
THE ECONOMY IS JUST GREAT.
INFLATION IS ONLY A TERM BEING
USED BY REPUBLICANS TO DRIVE
TURNOUT.
ACCORDING TO MSDNC EXPERT JOY
REID.
>> ONLY PEOPLE WHO USE THE WORD
"INFLATION" ARE JOURNALISTS AND
ECONOMISTS.
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE NORMAL
LEXICON OF THE WAY PEOPLE
TALKING.
REPUBLICANS DON'T USE THE COMMON
TONGUE, COMMON ENGLISH.
THEY'VE TAUGHT THE PEOPLE THE
WORD "INFLATION."
RIGHT?
MOST PEOPLE WHO NEVER USED THAT
WORD IN THEIR LIVES ARE USING IT
NOW BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN TAUGHT
IT.
>> Sean: JOY, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, AMERICANS KNOW WHAT
INFLATION IS, AND GUESS WHAT,
BECAUSE IT'S RUNNING THEIR
LIVES, CAUSED BY THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY, DRAINING THEIR
BANK ACCOUNTS, FORCING THEM INTO
CREDIT CARD DEBT.
SO JOY REID, WALKING POETIC
ABOUT THE WORD "INFLATION"
BECAUSE I GUESS SHE COULD AFFORD
TO.
SHE PROBABLY GETS PAID MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO DEMEAN, SLANDER
REPUBLICANS ON MS DNC, NOT
CHOOSING BETWEEN GAS OR FOOD,
NOT LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK,
AND 70% OF THE COUNTRY IS, AND
UNFORTUNATELY TOP DEMOCRATS
OBVIOUSLY DON'T CARE.
THEY PROBABLY DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT 2/3 OF THE COUNTRY PLUS ARE
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
PEOPLE ARE NOT MAKING ENDS MEET.
THEY ARE TOTALLY DETACHED AND
THE MEDIA MOB FROM REALITY.
THEIR AGENDA IS RADICAL.
THEIR POLICIES ARE INSANE.
THEIR GOALS ARE NAIVE AND
FAILING, AND THEIR CANDIDATES
ARE JUST AWFUL AND EXTREME.
BUT PERHAPS NO ONE IS WORSE THAN
THAT PENNSYLVANIA TRUST FUND
BRAT IN A HOODY THAT TRIES TO,
YOU KNOW, PLAY IT LIKE HE'S A
REAL HARD-WORKING BLUE COLLAR
WORKER.
HE'S A TRUST FUND BRAT IN A
HOODY, PRETENDS THAT HE'S A
WORKING MAN.
IT'S BASICALLY A HALLOWEEN
COSTUME ALL YEAR-ROUND EVERY
YEAR.
FETTERMAN'S NEVER HAD A REAL JOB
IN HIS LIFE UNTIL HE BECAME A
PART-TIME MAYOR OF A SMALL TOWN
OF BRADDOCK, PENNSYLVANIA.
AND LIKE MANY OTHER DEMOCRATS
RUNNING THIS YEAR, FETTERMAN IS
A DEVOUT RADICAL SOCIALIST.
THIS GUY WILL DESTROY
PENNSYLVANIA'S ECONOMY WITH HIS
MORATORIUM ON FRACKING.
HE WANTS TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
HE'S THE SINGLE BIGGEST
SUPPORTER OF CONVICTED MURDERERS
EVER TO RUN FOR THE U.S. SENATE.
HE WANTS TO EMPTY ALL PRISONS IN
PENNSYLVANIA, NATIONALIZE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY, PUNISH JOB
CREATORS, SOMETHING HE WOULDN'T
KNOW ABOUT, BECAUSE HE'S NEVER
HAD A JOB, MAKE PENNSYLVANIA A
SANCTUARY STATE, MAKE YOU THE
TAXPAYERS IN PENNSYLVANIA, PAY
FOR FREE HURRICANE-SAFE
INJECTION SITES.
RECENTLY HE SUFFERED A
DEBILITATING STROKE AND IS NOT
QUALIFIED TO SERVE FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS, BUT ACCORDING TO THE
LEFT, A VOTE FOR FETTERMAN IS,
WELL, AGAINST FETTERMAN IS AN
ACT OF VIOLENCE AGAINST HIM.
LIKE WHAT?
NOW ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATS YOU
ARE VOTING TO OVERTHROW
DEMOCRACY, THEY'LL A FASCIST,
ENEMIES OF THE STATE.
YOU WANT DIRTY AIR.
DIRTY WATER, PLOTTING AND
PLANNING AND SCHEMING TO TAKE
AWAY SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE, ALTHOUGH NOT A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN HAS EVER SAID IT.
DISRUPTIVE RHETORIC CAUSING
POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
THEY'RE TOTALLY IGNORING GOP
HOUSE CANDIDATE PAT HARRIGAN
JOINING US IN A MINUTE.
HIS FAMILY HOME, TAKE A LOOK,
THAT'S A BULLET HOLE, JUST SHOT
UP WHILE HIS CHILDREN WERE
SLEEPING INSIDE, BUT AGAIN
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA MOB,
THEY'RE NOT COVERING THE STORY,
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
FOR THEM EVERYTHING IS ONLY
ABOUT NARRATIVE.
IF IT DOESN'T FIT THEIR
POLITICAL AGENDA, IF IT DOESN'T
FIT THAT NARRATIVE, IT DOESN'T
EXIST, AND THEY IGNORE IT OF
COURSE O.
OF COURSE, THE NARRATIVE DOESN'T
FIX INFLATION, BRING DOWN ENERGY
COSTS.
IT DOESN'T SECURE THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE REAL CRIME
CRISIS IN SMALL TOWNS AND BIG
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T BRING
ANY OF US TOGETHER.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS FAILED
THIS COUNTRY ON A SPECTACULAR
LEVEL.
THEY HAVE LIED TO OUR FACES, AND
THEY NEED TO